RYAN LOREN: So Abiah, welcome.
ABIAH: Thank you very much.
RYAN LOREN: It's so
good to have you here.
I'm really looking
forward to this evening.
It's going to be great.
ABIAH: I'm excited to be here.
RYAN LOREN: Excellent.
So the first thing I
wanted to talk about
is just give us a
little bit of background
on how you came up and
started your music career
and what your influences
were growing up.
ABIAH: I started singing when
I was about nine years old.
And I come from a
slightly musical family.
My mother was a pianist for
the late opera singer William
Warfield.
So I grew up around
classical music,
and obviously, I grew up,
I used to go to church,
and I started in the choir.
But when I was about
nine years old,
I heard Anita Baker
sing "Sweet Love,"
and I fell in love with her
voice, but also with music,
at the moment.
So I started writing feverishly.
I would even fake sick to stay
home and try to write songs.
And within a year, I had
written a whole album of songs,
and I was writing and
writing and writing.
By 12, I probably
wrote 100 songs.
And so I had the bug very early.
RYAN LOREN: That's great.
When I stayed home from school,
I was not doing these things.
Playing video
games, and you know.
So that's great.
You got the passion
from a very early age
ABIAH: Absolutely.
RYAN LOREN: So can you talk to
me about your writing process?
Is it the same every
time, or do you-- how does
it evolve for you?
ABIAH: Honestly, I think
because I started so young,
the craft was being honed
at a very young age.
Obviously went
through high school,
I went to performing
arts high school,
the same school that Taye Diggs
attended, and Tweet the singer.
And so, I had this
really wonderful process
of people around me.
But for me, writing, music
comes to me pretty whole,
it's very through composed.
So when I get a song, usually
the lyrics, the melody,
the whole arrangement
comes at one time.
RYAN LOREN: OK.
And that leads me
to my next question.
Was your album, "Life is a
Ballad," from what I recall,
it was written and
done and recorded
in a very short period of time.
ABIAH: Yes, I wrote the
songs, majority of them,
within two weeks
of the recording,
and recorded the whole
record in one day.
RYAN LOREN: OK.
If you wouldn't
mind, I would like
to recite a few lyrics of yours.
ABIAH: Sure.
RYAN LOREN: So here we go.
It's not the same.
Every day whispers your name.
Since you've been gone,
the wind stops moving.
Now that you're gone,
it's a barren place.
Since you've been gone,
my heart is silent.
Life is a ballad,
the saddest song.
So if I had to guess, you've
been through some things,
you know.
But tell me where the title
of the album came from,
and also what inspired you to
write this particular song.
Because I find it gorgeous.
Like, it's hard for me to
even keep a straight face
while reading that
because I want to tear up.
But it's beautiful, and I just
wanted to ask you about that.
ABIAH: I appreciate that.
"Life is a Ballad," the
title actually came to me
about four years ago.
So even before I
wrote the record,
I had the title for the record.
I knew what it was
going to be called,
but I didn't have the song
yet, that one particular song.
But just before Oprah
Winfrey went off the network,
I was watching her show,
and it was around the time
that Steve Irwin, the
crocodile hunter had died.
He was killed by the stingray.
And his wife and his
children were on there
and they were crying.
And the wife said, ever since he
left, the wind stopped moving.
And it touched me very deeply.
And the song just started
pouring out of me,
and I really like 15 minutes.
I was waiting for the
inspiration of the title,
and it made perfect
sense at that moment.
RYAN LOREN: That's great.
So when you write, it's not
only from your own experiences.
Is that true?
ABIAH: Yeah, "Life is a Ballad"
is unlike my first album.
This album was really
not so autobiographical.
Only two songs are my real
life stories, "Foolish Heart"
and "Turn the Light
On," which is, I know,
one of your favorites.
But the rest of the
record was really
about me just
being a storyteller
and telling stories.
I mean, when you
have great friends
and you experience
people's stories
through their own heart, I
think, their own experiences,
it can inspire you.
And I happen to be
drawn to melancholy.
Even when I'm in the
happiest moments of my life,
for some reason I can always
write from a very sad place.
But in the midst of that, I
think there's always hope.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah, I think
that's a common thread
throughout the whole
album for those of you
who haven't listened to it,
and I would suggest you should.
OK, so a couple of
things before we wrap up.
I know you do vocal coaching--
ABIAH: I do.
RYAN LOREN: --as well.
Just real quick, what's
one of the challenges
you face with that, and
what's one thing you like
a lot about it, to
both sides of that?
ABIAH: The first
part is that people
come in a lot of times
with the wrong expectation.
I think we live in a
very microwave society,
and people want quick
results like that.
But someone like me, people come
to me because of my reputation
as a singer.
But I put years into my
craft of working on it
and making sure that I'm a
singer worthy of the calling.
And so, when people
come in and they say,
oh, I want to
sound like Beyonce.
Well, there's only one Beyonce.
And you may not
have that talent,
but let's see what we can
do by sculpting and working
on the craft to be
the best thing that we
can be based on what
God has given us.
But what I love about
it is the process.
I think that if someone
is patient and willing
to be vulnerable and do the
homework, meaning study,
I think that it's an incredible
experience to watch people.
Even the singer,
Kimberly Nicole,
who's performing tonight,
she's someone that I coach.
And to see her who's a bit
more seasoned as a singer,
and to be able to add to what
she does, is a real person.
RYAN LOREN: That's great.
I'm going to have to
disagree with one thing.
I sound a lot like Beyonce.
ABIAH: Oh really?
That's your shower voice.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
So I want to play a
game with you real fast.
It's called Bob Dylan
or Backstreet Boys.
If you could just tell
me, is this Bob Dylan
or Backstreet Boys?
OK.
If not for you, babe, I
couldn't find the door.
Couldn't even see the floor.
I'd be said and
blue if not for you.
Bob Dylan, or Backstreet Boys?
ABIAH: Backstreet Boys.
RYAN LOREN: Bob Dylan.
No.
It's a tough one.
I think this these
very, very well.
OK.
So--
ABIAH: Yes you did.
RYAN LOREN: Tell us, levity
aside, what's next for you
after Life is a Ballad?
ABIAH: So already, based on the
response of "Life is a Ballad,"
I've decided to record
a new record already.
So I'm going to go in the studio
probably within the next four
to six weeks and knock
out a new record.
Yeah, so that's
what's on the plate,
and I'm really excited about it
RYAN LOREN: Great.
Well, thanks so
much for being here.
ABIAH: Thank you, Ryan.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah, definitely.
Cool.
ABIAH: Thank you.